This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tells us in the
Quran A man pleading with Allah to send
him back so he could give Sadaqah. Why
Sadaqah? Because he knows the weight of
Sadaqah. Just 100 pounds. You can help
teach [music]
20 to 60 people to learn
>> how to perform Salah, recite Surah
Fatiha, and make Wudu. Click the link
and donate now.
Salam
Get up on THE CAMERA.
OH, ABDUL KARIM, what are we doing
today? We are going to the Light Upon
Light event on the last Jumu'ah of
Ramadan. May Allah accept it from all of
us. And what are we taking to the event?
>> Taking 1,000
prayer mats. No, no, no, no, no. We're
taking 1,500
prayer mats. And what are we doing?
We're giving it out FOR FREE. FOR WHAT?
FOR FREE. FOR WHAT? FOR FREE.
>> OH [screaming] MY GOD. AS-SALAMU
ALAYKUM. WE HAVE We have a special guest
on the We have many special guests.
Masha Allah. I just heard about the
Salah Pro lighted mats, and I want to
know more about it, Insha Allah. So, do
you remember about a year ago you gave a
shout-out?
>> Yes. So, alhamdulillah, we get these now
for 75% cheaper. Okay.
>> So, you know we're a charity, we give it
for free. Yes.
>> So, we ordered 50,000 last year, Yeah.
and we thought it would last us 1 year.
It finished in 4 months. Wow.
>> putting an order of 100,000 this year,
Insha Allah.
So, this is what it looks like. Yeah,
here it is. Here it is.
>> And also it's got like a Wudu guide, how
to pray. Here you go. I'll hold it for
you, yeah. I have to do Wudu, how to
pray, Insha Allah, yeah.
So, yeah, it's for free. The app is for
free, the mat is for free. We have Salah
instructors that teach you for free.
Alhamdulillah, yeah. May Allah bless
you. How are you? How are you doing? So,
it helps people to actually uh pray.
>> Yes. Yes. Cuz first
Yeah, first time ever, you can cuz
usually in the Dawah, it would take time
for you to pray Salah. Now,
it's revolutionary cuz now you can put
it in front of you. There's no excuse in
missing Salah cuz you know, Mufti, I was
going to ask you to give a reminder
about Salah. And it's all
transliterations. Transliterations? In
Italian, German, French, Spanish,
Portuguese, Albanian, English. And we're
doing it in Japanese this year. Well, I
tell you one thing, from my angle, I
think obviously salah is one of the most
important pillars in Islam. There are
five pillars, all of them are important,
but salah is a cornerstone. And one of
the first things we're going to be
reckoned regarding is prayer. If your
prayer is in order, the rest will be in
order. So, to help someone to pray, you
get a full reward for the prayer that
that person prayed. Even if you're just
encouraging someone to encourage someone
to pray, you get a full reward for that
prayer anyway. So, mashallah, it's a
really good initiative where we're
trying to encourage people to pray. And
may Allah make it easy for everyone. And
I'm glad to see you here today. And I
pray that inshallah Allah continue to
use us to do good work, inshallah.
Inshallah. Just a quick reminder for
those watching, if you are not praying
salah, or they feel like they're
sinners, they call Some people call them
Ramadan Muslims. What message would you
give to those people who feel
So, there are two ways of looking at it.
You know, there is a way of looking at
it where you feel the guilt. Obviously,
that is a part of it. But, to what
extent? If that guilt is felt to the
extent where you don't feel like praying
ever again because you think Allah is
merciless, then you're going in the
wrong direction. You're heading towards
shaytan. But, if the guilt is felt in a
way that makes you feel that you want to
develop a link with Allah, then it's a
good guilt.
You know, something positive. But,
together with that, I like to also tell
people the second part of it is don't
look at what you didn't do. Look at what
you can do.
Because if you're going to keep looking
at what you didn't do, you might regret
to the degree that it makes you
despondent, like I said. But, when you
look at what you can do, inshallah, it's
it it goes to open doors for that which
you probably never thought that you
would be able to achieve. Start it
today. Don't give up. Keep getting up.
Every time you miss a prayer, keep
getting up and do and you know, do the
qada. And and at least don't miss
another prayer. Each time you seek
Allah's forgiveness, don't do it again.
If you happen to fall,
try again. Try again. You will become
more and more regular with your prayer,
and the day will come when inshallah it
will be so easy to fulfill that prayer.
Inshallah. And I have
One quick thing Allah chooses whom he
wants to worship him. So when Allah when
you pray it's actually Allah who chose
you to pray but the effort needs to come
from you. He wants a good heart and an
effort. You make a good heart and an
effort you will be chosen. You know when
you say who wants a gold bar put up your
hand. Everybody puts up their hands. You
going to choose right? But they have it
they had to put up their hands. Same
applies with us. We have to make the
effort and we have to try and then Allah
accepts it. So we shouldn't ever give
up. May Allah bless you brother.
So as you can see guys Mufti came made a
nice surprise for us. He's always
He's always supported the cause and like
I said to you guys before even with the
early stages when we had our map
subhanallah teaching people how to pray
salah and sisters Mufti Menk, Omar
Suleiman, Undertaker, brother Osama has
always been here supporting the project
and we're here to teach people how to
pray salah and there you go put them
upside down
so yeah I'm going to say that's why it's
so important for you guys to support the
cause sisters. It was a nice surprise
from Mufti.
This is the new sadaqah jariya in town.
Allah [music] subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us in the Quran a man pleading with
Allah to send him back so he could give
sadaqah. Why sadaqah? Because he knows
the weight of sadaqah. Just 100 pounds
you can help teach 20 to 60 people to
learn
>> how to perform salah [music] recite
surah fatiha and make wudu. Click the
link and donate now.